bonjour david ce passeport vaccinale
sera l'un des principaux points de débat
en tout cas cet après midi à bruxelles
mais il sera surtout question des
retards de production des vaccins
évidemment et pour qu'il y ait débat
magali il faut que d'abord que tous les
habitants de l'union européenne elles
soient vaccinés et ça ne concerne pour
l'instant que 5 % de la population ce
qui va forcément diviser un responsable
est tout trouvé astrazeneca qui a
reconnu de nouvelles difficultés de
production en europe pour les doses
promises à l'union européenne au second
semestre le géant pharmaceutique a
certifié la livraison de 180 millions de
12 en utilisant l fait capacité à
mondiale afin d'assurer à cette promesse
car oui la campagne de vaccination a
pris énormément de retard à travers
l'union européenne et les 27 membres
vont forcément a demandé à des comptes
cet après midi ursula von der leyen de
son côté préfère rester optimiste
afin d'atténuer les tensions existantes
entre l'union européenne et le groupe
britannique au suédois
les fabricants de vaccins sont nos
partenaires dans cette pandémie
et si de nouvelles questions sont
toujours à l'ordre du jour nous les
résolvons généralement à l'amiable
je pense qu'il est préférable de
travailler avec des entreprises à
l'amélioration de la production mondiale
et les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes 1
selon le décompte effectué par bloomberg
l union européenne injecté à ce stade
que si doses de vaccin pour 100
habitants
l affaire a également causé une tension
diplomatique avec le royaume uni qui est
vous le savez a définitivement acquis t
elle le bloc européen à bruxelles
accusant implicitement astrazeneca de
réserver un traitement préférentiel à la
grande bretagne au détriment de l'union
européenne et c'est vrai que quand on
regarde l ces chiffres sur ce graphique
est bien la différence est flagrante
entre le royaume uni et les autres pays
européens ce sommet aura donc pour but
d'envoyer un message de coordination
européenne pour ne pas à créer de
fragmentation dans la campagne de
vaccination européenne l'unité de
l'union européenne à rude épreuve on l'a
vu
à cause de ce vaccin la vaccination qui
vient action qui s'accentue et pardon ce
constat d'éclatement david effectivement
magali et et l'objectif à d'ursula von
der leyen
et bien c'est justement de fédérer pour
éviter que l'union européenne éclatée
que chaque pays choisissent le chacun
pour soi à titre d'exemple la hongrie
qui a choisi d'acheter le vaccin à
aarhus spoutnik v et à ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que la présidente de la
commission européenne a fait son mea
culpa auprès des députés européens au
début du mois en mettant une certaine
pression au laboratoire astrazeneca
écoutez nous travaillerons aussi dur que
possible pour atteindre notre objectif
de faire vacciner 70 % de la population
adulte en europe d'ici à la fin de l'été
et pourtant il est un fait que nous ne
sommes pas là où nous voulions être
aujourd'hui dans la lutte contre le
virus
ils doivent prouver qu'ils ont honoré
leur contrat nous attendons donc
astrazeneca remplisse ses engagements
cela signifie livrer la totalité des
commandes
même s'ils ont pour cela besoin de plus
de temps notre but n'est pas d'avoir un
conflit juridique mais d'avoir des
vaccins ne pas déchirer l'europe tout en
restant solidaires avec les pays les
plus pauvres notamment en afrique un
ursula von der leyen est favorable à
l'initiative d' emmanuel macron pour que
les états unis et l'europe donnent 5 %
elle de leurs réserves de vaccins contre
le coc u19 à l'afrique
encore faut-il avoir ces fameux vaccin
et vous le vous l'aurez compris le jeu
d'équilibriste auquel est confrontée la
présidente de la commission européenne
est particulièrement délicat mais on
verra tout ça évidemment dans nos
prochaines éditions merci beaucoup david
pour toutes ces précisions